get on your toes let's make sure we're
playing a faster game here tonight guys
we want to be really good in that category
on it and above it on it means touching
pucks first above it means when we haven't
touched the puck first we're above the speed
through the middle of the Ring need that
start boys Bo your line ready to go wegs
honey [Applause] Marky ready to take the
Battle of Alberta outside the flames and
Oilers in the Tim Horton Heritage Classic from
soldout Commonwealth Stadium [Applause] [Music]
such a unique experience one that only you know
you maybe get to experience once or twice if
you're lucky so just trying to soak it all in the
38th outdoor game in NHL history is set to get
underway like moving the rebounds and
anary kid has the opening goal hey box
and one stay in the box and one let's
move it no let up here he no let up
Puck keep going forward here puck gets by
him though and ddle is going to pick it up
and now we've got a two-on one ddle
centers it h shoots and [Applause]
scor you ready you ready for a cross grease
anny huie hubero steps in swung it shot
Wier tip home in front he scores and it's
conre with a deflection upstairs on Stewart
[Music]
Skinner stay away from the puck
buddy Puck doesn't want you
okay now the battle fully engaged what are
you going to do what are you going to do I
got what is anybody here going to do let's go
this way something you're not even in my league
he's got to fight a guy like you first and show
me what he's got he in my league not looking at
much not looking at much Fifth Line guy now
Fifth Line guy keep going boys you're playing
with more Pace they can't handle you hman kept
it alive down low centering past Conor McDavid
but hooks to the corner ped across and now a
dish onetime rip score and Bard through screen
and Edon extends to a 3-1 lead the Oilers get it
right back I'm going to go here one shift at a
time here hey you want to pick and roll y weaves
his way across the orders line gets through Waker
shoots it's stop rebound to Career he scores
the Flames get back to within one three to
two come on man stay on it here [Music] e a shot
from the point and the Evon Oilers extend to a 42
lead you're going to pull him early here there
goes markom to the bench chopped down amander
kan's got an empty net and he scores
this game's over Edmonton five Calgary
two oh good job well the four game windw
streak for the Oilers has ended here at
tomwell Stadium I just want to tell this
group that's guts heart and passion that
we need to play with every night
you should be proud of that effort
because everybody in here is proud of that
group well done guys well [Applause] done